with man united we're what a year and a
half into the project now I don't know
what they do po chatino has got the got
the thing on his side of a lot of the
signings haven't been his signings so
far 10 Hogs have been his signings and
again you look at the ones he's bought
in and for the most part the big money
spent it ain't gone down well so I'm
looking at the project now and I'm
thinking going forward who would I
rather have there I'd rather have poino
the difference between ten hog and poino
is ten hog gets results pettino is not
getting results so you can have the
style of play which is great we we need
that style of play we need a style of
play we need an identity but you got to
get the results and portino so far in
his career he showed it at Spurs he
doesn't get over the line PSG he
couldn't handle the big personalities he
didn't want to handle Neymar he didn't
want to handle Messi he didn't want to
handle mbappe and in the end he ends up
leaving out the back door yeah he won a
league arm but it wasn't it didn't move
them at all so so what you see with
portino is that he's a little bit of a
nearly man for me